[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKE KARNS: "Hamilton" is
one of the most talked about
and best loved musicals,
with shows on Broadway,
in London, and
around the country.
We wanted something
to make the show more
accessible for our fans.
So we wanted to develop an
app to meet the needs of fans
as we started to
expand the brand.
We turned to Posse, a
New-York-based development firm
to help us develop
the Hamilton app.
DAVID DEREMER:
"Hamilton's" Flutter app
launched in the App
Store and the Play Store
three months after we wrote
our first line of code.
And we accomplished a ton.
Fans can enter a daily lottery
for a shot at $10 tickets,
buy merchandise through
an e-commerce experience,
take selfie photos
with the Ham Cam,
and get daily news and updates.
JESSICA WAGNER: We knew
that this app needed
to be rock solid, both
in terms of performance
and visual fidelity,
and really represent
the amazing experience
that the "Hamilton" show
itself provides.
And ultimately, that's why
we decided to use Flutter.
MARTIN AGUINIS: Flutter
is a mobile UI toolkit
that allows developers
and designers to craft
beautiful native experiences
on iOS and Android,
and is entirely free
and open source.
DAVID DEREMER: We have very
high expectations of quality
for the apps that we build.
We expect pixel-perfect results.
And we need them to be
very high performance.
Flutter gave us a lot of
opportunities that previously
weren't available to us.
The fact that it's
a single code base
drastically improved
our ability to deliver
a consistent experience
across platforms.
Its hot reload
gives us an ability
to build more
features in less time.
ALBERT LARDIZABAL: It allowed
me to make changes really fast
and iterate through
the UI without having
to stop or restart the app.
Coming from an iOS and
Android background,
it's something that I've been
waiting for for a long time.
The Flutter developer
community is very active.
Drop-in packages helped
us maximize productivity.
It helped us integrate elements
like Firebase and Cloud.
DAVID DEREMER: At
the end of the day,
we're just really happy
that we found Flutter
so that we can build these
beautiful native interfaces
for both iOS and Android
from a single code base.
JESSICA WAGNER: We were given
a really tight timeline,
and we turned the app
around faster than I ever
could have imagined.
We were able to make changes
right up to the night
before we went live and really
feel confident about them.
In fact, we pushed an
entirely new feature
to the App Store the
day before we launched.
DAVID DEREMER: And since launch,
Flutter's efficiency and speed
has helped us to
build new features,
such as the recent trivia game.
We're really excited because
as the show continues to grow,
we're going to be able to keep
pace with a ton of new features
that's going to make
the app even better.
JESSICA WAGNER: We couldn't
be more thrilled with Flutter.
It has enabled us to use one
code base to deliver a truly
high-quality app that
"Hamilton" fans have absolutely
fallen in love with.
MIKE KARNS: We're thrilled with
what Posse was able to deliver.
The entire brand
of "Hamilton" is
about delivering on an
experience for fans.
They're thrilled about the new
feature set we're rolling out.
And we're really excited to
see where the app goes next.
[MUSIC PLAYING]